all right this is a fox news alert
president trump's attorney rudy giuliani
weighing in on
buzzfeed's fake report on twitter
writing quote i commend
bob mueller's office for correcting the
buzzfeed false story
that president trump encouraged cohn to
lie i asked the press
to take heed that their hysterical
desire to destroy this president
has gone too far they push this without
critical analysis
all day fake news we go now to the
president's attorney
jay sekulow also the chief counsel for
the american center for law and justice
um you know this is how it went all day
jay
well if we haven't verified it ourselves
but if true and this is both the
democrats
and the media but if true and then they
go to impeachment
and this is now going on for two
straight years false report after false
report conspiracy theory after
conspiracy theory
you know i think one of the networks uh
one of the other networks i think i
counted in the course of a little less
than an hour
17 or 19 times they said if this was
true
if this happened if these facts could be
verified which we haven't been able to
verify
this would be a crime that's like saying
you know if if someone robbed a bank it
would be a crime well if someone did rob
a bank it would be a crime
but i think it's important here for a
moment to reflect on that this was
actually a good day
uh for justice and a very very good day
for the president of the united states
but it's also important to say and and
to focus for a moment here
on what the special counsel's office
actually said and sean because you know
my job
as the president's lawyers part of the
legal team is to analyze these things
and to
respond to what was going on this frenzy
that was going on the last
oh 24 hours and so let me start with
what the what he actually said
this is from bob mueller's office by the
way it's the first time they have spoken
publicly
about a false news story this is what
they said buzzfeed's description of
specific statements to the special
counsel's office
that's one and characterization of
documents
that's two and testimony obtained by
this office
regarding michael cohen's congressional
testimony
are not accurate so it's three things
it's the description of the specific
statements to the special counsel's
office
the characterization of the documents
that were the basis upon which the media
speculation started
and the testimony obtained by the office
regarding
michael cohen's cooperation with the
special counsel's office
all of that as reported in the report
today are not correct and this isn't
coming from me
it's not coming from the american center
for law and justice it's not coming from
my law firm who's it coming from it's
coming from the special counsel's office
bob mueller's office so i think rudy
giuliani is right
in saying that this was the right thing
to do and i'm glad they did it now
where does that leave us so sean here's
what i think this is
this is a warning sign to everybody
that the speculation with no factual
backup
is dangerous for our republic and
look i've been dealing with this as you
know uh for for more than 24 hours about
24 hours
actually it started last night about 10
o'clock so about an hour from now and
uh the end result of this was the right
thing but it took us 24 hours to get the
right thing
but i think it's important for everyone
that's watching to realize
that the speculation and the media
anxiousness
to report out of the gate has got to
stop but there's also another message in
all this and you said this in your
monologue
look what is transpired people say is
there any action being taken on the
people that are doing
uh wrong deeds illegal conduct
well let's look at it james baker the
general counsel of the fbi is under
investigation
for what leaking to the media
andrew mckay just say something but jake
we just learned that this week
comey's fbi you have his deputy
andrew mccabe is under a criminal
investigation now the general counsel
for leaking
for leaking this is important for
leaking
they're not supposed to be doing that
and they're leaking documents
and they're leaking testimony and at
least leaking statements and this is
this is
absolutely that's why they're fired and
under investigation
you know the media buyers focus on that
yep
false reporting which we have documented
and i
believe the president has forever
branded rightly so
fake news as such and for them to ever
get their credibility back
i don't think it's even possible you
know look look at this we learned about
the general counsel baker
we know about andrew mccabe we know
about strzok and page they were even
appointed to mueller's team along with
jeannie ray who used to be clinton's
attorney in
the pit bull andrew weissman but here's
my question bruce or we learned
under oath in testimony released this
week
that in fact he warned everybody about
the phony dossier
he warned that clinton paid for it he
warned that christopher steele had a
hatred of the president
and he warned that it wasn't verified or
corroborated
but it still it came but there's another
summation
is that yeah i've always asked the
question
of what happens to the evidence that was
gathered during the course of the
proceedings
the investigation that were outside
legal parameters not appropriate not
legal because call the fruit of the
poisonous tree
but but let me tell you something else
about the bruce ohr testament bruce ohr
did say that he told the higher ups at
the fbi
my gosh he was the number four that in
fact that the dossier was biased that it
was paid for by political operatives
but his wife worked for the political
operative company that put the dossier
together
and and and there's also simultaneous
with his mia culpa
from bruce ohr is what our text messages
that have been released
between bruce ohr and who christopher
seal the so-called uh british spy
and that is a plea for bruce or
and chris chris steele for steele to
come back to work
to the fbi right after james comey's
fired now ask yourself this question
why was christopher steele fired by the
fbi in the first place and you know what
the answer to that one is
a leak to the media so this is
look the illegitimacy of the inquiry
from the outset has been
is is is incredible but it's the
consistency
of getting information out here so again
while i'm glad that the office of the
special counsel's office today
issued this very clear three-part
statement and that's how you have to
analyze it and some of these networks
trying to parse it
it's it's almost funny watching it but
here's what i think is important what's
the consistent
theme through this illegal inappropriate
leaks and who started leaking as well
james comey he said he gave his notes of
a conversation he had with the president
of the united states
to a friend of his to leak to the press
so he would get the appointment of a
special counsel
which lo and behold happens so let me
tell you something
that's what i want everybody focusing on
tonight is this consistent
pattern of leaking and that's going on
at the highest it's not the individual
fbi agents
in mass they do a great job but the
stroke and page thing
someone explained this one to me there
are emails that are missing or text
messages
from the time that they were at the
special counsel's office and the
resource officer
at the special counsel's office says
well we didn't really check
the material and one phone was left and
the other phone was recirculated
and no one checked the text messaging so
look again i am glad that bob mueller's
office
issued this statement it was called for
it was due it was the appropriate thing
to do
but there are a lot of questions that
are still not answered
by the activities that taken place here
now again it's a good day for the pres
great day for the president
great day for the country not such a
great day for the media and i caution
friends of mine in the media
today to watch this be very careful here
you you'd be very
early on source unverified yes we saw
the two buzzfeed one reporter says
uh yeah we saw the evidence the other
said we didn't and
of course they released the the dossier
without any corroboration
you know here's the dangerous part in
the serious part of all of this
it's hurting the country this is an
obsession congress
you know if if verified impeachment
impeachment impeachment
this has been the burden on this
president now for two years
and it was interesting to watch today
the media also
um feeling that thinking obstruction of
justice is a really serious issue
while ignoring the deletion of
subpoenaed emails
bleach bit hammers sim cards removed
and you know we saw last week democrats
say manufacture crisis media says
manufacture crisis again and again
it's almost as if they they want this to
happen so bad they cannot well they
cannot get over this obsession
which really is hate and really hurts
the country
well look this this impacts the
president the office of the presidency
and the entire country but let me say
something
if you look at the other networks which
i know you don't do but in my job i got
to look at all of it right
so when i saw that i'm sorry i'm sorry
that you had today that's that's
punishment yeah
you know what he said though special
counsel's office
challenges buzzfeed's statements
regarding the president directing
someone to lie
that's all i needed to say for the day
there you go
jay sekulow president chief counsel
american center for law and justice
thank you